und wir fragen nach bei valerie höhne
vom spiegel ich grüße sie verhöhne die
grünen und die fdp haben sich offenbar
auf ein erstes treffen morgen geeinigt
das ist ja ein novum dass sich die
kleinen so nenne ich sie jetzt mal
zuerst zusammenfinden inwieweit ist das
denn auch eine entwertung des
führungspersonals der großen parteien
es ist natürlich es ist ein unheimlich
spannender prozess jetzt aber die
parteien
dass parteien bild hat sich ein bisschen
verschoben in diesem land nach dieser
wahl weil keine partei mehr über 30
kommt das heißt es ist jetzt so eine
historische chance glaube ich für die
kleinen parteien etwas zu etablieren zum
beispiel dass sie als königsmacher
zusammen kommen und vorher schon mal vor
sondieren was denn ihre gemeinsamen
projekte sind und das ist glaube ich es
ist glaube ich sehr interessant ist
glaube ich schon eine verschiebung des
machtgefüges und die beiden großen die
cdu/csu und auch die spd lassen darf
federn aber es ist auch es könnte auch
eine gute nachricht sein weil wir eben
2017 gesehen haben dass fdp und grüne
einfach gar nicht zusammenkamen und es
dann keine jamaika koalition gab es
stattdessen eine große koalition das ist
ja was was viele hier heute verhindern
wollen dass es eine wiederauflage der
großen koalition dann unter spd-führung
gibt von daher ist es vielleicht gar
nicht so schlecht wenn fdp und grüne
sich vorher einmal beschnuppern so dass
mögliche sondierungen und auch koalition
dann auch bestand haben und und nicht
und es nicht wieder heißt besser nicht
regieren als schlecht regieren wir haben
es sagen ja jetzt auch alle die
sondierungsgespräche müssen komplett
anders laufen als eben 2017 aber was
muss denn genau anders werden also was
die inhalte angeht aber auch das
personal das daran teilnimmt
er wird ja jetzt viel gesagt dass es
nicht um spiegel striche gehen soll das
die sondierungsteams wesentlich kleiner
sein sollen die spd hat jetzt ein
sechsköpfiges team erstmal angekündigt
bei den grünen soll es personell auch
viel viel kleiner sein soll nicht so
groß sein wie es bei den jamaika
sondierung der fall war und dann ist es
natürlich so dass die parteien versuchen
werden die durchstechereien an die
presse ihn zu einem minimum zu
reduzieren
das heißt dass sozusagen nicht die
verhandlungen sofort nach außen getragen
werden jetzt ist es aber so dass während
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in der
decke runter zeit doch auch relativ viel
durch gestochen wurde von daher bin ich
sehr gespannt ob die parteien
tatsächlich diese disziplin waren können
je kleiner die teams desto
wahrscheinlicher natürlich dass es das
weniger an die öffentlichkeit gelangt da
sind wir alle gespannt schauen wir noch
mal auf die grünen das scheint sicher
gerade die reihenfolge rangfolge bei
annalena baerbock und robert habeck zu
verändern wird er denn nun die
hauptrolle übernehmen jetzt in den
sondierungsgesprächen und später dann
vielleicht als vizekanzler
er versucht das ganz offenbar zumindest
scheint es diese absprache gegeben zu
haben zwischen diesen beiden zwischen
annalena baerbock und robert habeck aber
es gibt jetzt auch schon kritik aus der
partei jürgen trittin hat heute morgen
dem spiegel gesagt dass dieses das ist
das nicht zwei personen festlegen wer
vizekanzler wird oder er hat gesagt wer
wäre posten besetzt sondern dass die
partei entscheidet auch bei der
kandidatenfindung hat die partei eine
sehr untergeordnete rolle gespielt hatte
im prinzip keine rolle gespielt sondern
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
haben das im hinterzimmer entschieden
das scheinen sie jetzt fortführen zu
wollen ich bin gespannt ob sie damit
durchkommen aber es ist so dass er auf
jeden fall jetzt den also er wird jetzt
auf jeden fall wieder eine wichtige
rolle spielen er möchte offenbar auch
vizekanzler werden das zumindest scheint
der fall zu sein und und er wird darum
kämpfen dass die partei sich jetzt
wieder eher ihm unterordnet nachdem
annalena baerbock diese wahl man kann
das glaube ich nicht anders sagen
verloren hat für die grünen schließlich
sind sie zehn prozentpunkte hinter union
und spd gelandet und wollten führende
kraft in diesem land werden dieses
wahlziel haben sie einfach wirklich
grandios verfehlt schauen wir auf
mögliche bündnisse inwieweit spielten
die freundschaft zwischen armin laschet
und christian lindner dabei eine rolle
also das persönliche bei so einer
bindung
ich glaube das spielt schon eine relativ
große rolle vor allem weil spd und grüne
sich in den vergangenen vier jahren
nicht besonders gut verstanden haben was
eben auch daran lag dass die grünen
immer vor der spd lagen und die spd das
nicht goutiert hat auf der einen seite
auf der anderen seite natürlich die
grünen auch mit dem entsprechenden ego
aufgetreten sind deswegen gibt es
reibereien zwischen den fraktionen seit
jahren da ist
das heißt sie sind sich einfach nicht so
nah wie cdu und fdp im moment und so
eine persönliche verbindung kann schon
wirklich auch konsequenzen haben ich
finde dann sieht es auch am wahlabend
und auch schon vorher wenn lindner sich
nicht so klar zu laschet gestanden wäre
oder gehalten hätte dann dann würden wir
jetzt vielleicht gar nicht diese diese
diskussionen immer noch haben um jamaika
versus ampel wenn jetzt doch ja relativ
klar ist dass die spd die wahl gewonnen
hat und der wahlsieger ist trotzdem ist
es ja immer noch so dass zumindest heute
noch darüber diskutiert wird ob es
jamaica geben könnte auch wenn jetzt die
rücktrittsforderung natürlich aus der
cdu lauter werden und es so scheint dass
die partei so unsortiert ist das nicht
sicher ist ob sie tatsächlich in
sondierung und dann auch in
koalitionsverhandlungen eintreten könnte
es gibt hier stimmen die sagen die spd
könne richtig froh sein dass es für rot
grün rot letztendlich nicht reichen
würde sonst hätte innerparteiliche
wieder einmal eine zerreißprobe bei
diesem thema angestanden sehen sie das
auch so ich sehe dass ehrlicherweise ein
bisschen anders ich glaube
mit der option rot grün rot hätte
scheutz einen stärkeren impetus gehabt
für die fdp in eine ampel einzutreten
weil in dem moment
hätte die fdp eine linksregierung in der
bundesrepublik verhindern können und das
können sie fast nicht nicht machen jetzt
ist dass sie eher die wahl haben wobei
wenn die cdu wenn das jetzt weitergeht
wenn die cdu sich
nach und nach
mir fehlen jetzt ein besseres wort
zerlegt dann natürlich trotzdem die
ampel die die konsequenz daraus wenn das
sozusagen die einzige lösung bleibt
außer es gibt eine wiederauflage der
großen koalition unter spd-führung was
natürlich fdp und grüne unbedingt
verhindern wollen weil sie ja regieren
wollen wie sicher können wir denn alle
sein dass es nicht eine neue große
koalition geben wird im moment würde ich
mich auch überhaupt nichts festlegen ich
weiß es nicht ich glaube nicht dass es
eine neue große koalition geben wird
aber ich glaube schon dass werden fdp
und grüne zu viel fordern und sich
vielleicht auch nicht einigen können
weil sie beide das gefühl haben dass sie
das jetzt unbedingt was reißen müssen
für ihr klientel
dann könnte es natürlich so kommen dass
es tatsächlich eine wiederauflage der
großen koalition gibt weil man neuwahlen
verhindern möchte ich finde aber das
wäre wirklich schwach von von allen
beteiligten partnern deswegen hoffe ich
sehr dass es dass es nicht soweit kommt
die einschätzung von valerie höhne vom
spiegel vielen dank danke